tom simpson est mort un peu avant 6
heures ce soir à l'hôpital d'avignon où
il avait été transporté par hélicoptère
après sa chute dans le mont ventoux
l'équipe de l'actualité télévisée qui
fait un reportage sur les à-côtés du
tour de france se trouvaient à proximité
de tom simpson
lorsque l'accident s'est produit je vous
propose tout de suite de voir le
document car c'est un document que nous
ont envoyé nos envoyés spéciaux
maurice séveno et jean louis normand
regardez nous sommes à trois kilomètres
du sommet du mont ventoux et nous
arrivons à la hauteur de tom simpson qui
titube sur la route
aidés par des spectateurs qui veulent
absolument le faire repartir mais il en
est incapable
normal caméraman et damien son moteur
s'arrête et sur les derniers moments de
tom simpson
et affalé sur sa machine incapables une
réaction d'un geste alors on va
l'étendre
quelques instants plus tard
l'hélicoptère l'évacuation l'hôpital
d'avignon à 19 heures monsieur félix
lévitan annonce tom simpson le champion
du monde est mort
depuis lors nous avons appris que le
permis d'inhumer a été refusé une
enquête sera donc ouverte
c'est un document c'est pourquoi nous
avons pensé qu'il fallait vous le
montrer tout de suite d'autres
informations vous